the opening scene features the king Yan
sect that consists of Seven Peaks of
kung fu school we are firstly Shan Dau
Peak where six of its disciples and the
daughter of Dau Peak master named tition
are practicing martial arts in the vast
Sky meanwhile a student named Xiang
xiaan who is a beginner is still working
on his first level of kung fu being a
pure-hearted human being who carries out
all the chores shaan is well-liked by
everyone the boy has a crush on tition
who always supports him in his training
and takes care of him like an elder
sister during a meal shaan becomes the
topic of discussion as he struggles to
progress in kung fu despite nearly a
decade in the sect however he asserts
his commitment claiming to be at the
final stage of his first level of
training in order to test his progress
Master Shang places his hand on shaan's
chest as a result of this shaan starts
leaning backwards so tion secretly helps
him from behind and he likes likes it
one day while training together with
tion shaan recalls that it's the same
day when his parents passed away sensing
his grief tion uses her flying skills to
take him to his village once there shaan
recounts a tragic incident of how he
witnessed his village being struck by
lightning and thunderstorm as they
entered the village he saw his father
who is a Kung Fu Master fighting with
the masked leader of the demon sect as
the battle intensified both of them used
their mystical powers resulting in a
huge explosion this killed all the
villagers except for shaan and his
friend Jing Yu as they were grieving the
death of their loved ones Master Shang
arrived at the scene with his daughter
and some soldiers shaen bowed before him
pleading with him to make him his
disciple so that he can avenge his
parents in the future 10 years have
passed since that incident but shaan has
found nothing about the murderers in the
next scene we see the Kung Fu masters
from all Seven Peaks gather at a place
in order to talk about the Kung Fu
tournament it appears that the students
from all the Peaks will be participating
in it and the winner will be regarded as
the leader of the king Yun sect later
that evening students from the six Peaks
sneak through the bushes to watch the
Shia Shu Peaks training upon reaching
there they are a struck by the
exceptional skill of shui one of the
Disciples of Shia Shu amidst the
spectacle shaan is unexpectedly pushed
forward drawing attention to himself as
as a result shui and her fellow female
disciples apprehend him for trespassing
while the other students hastily Retreat
as a penalty Shuki leaves several
itching worms on shaan before letting
him go in the aftermath Tian reprimands
all the students for their actions and
warns them against a repeat offense she
instructs the disciples to stand guard
outside before applying medicinal powder
to rid shaan of the itching worms he
doesn't have the heart to tell her that
he kind of likes them them the next day
shaan visits a lake with pumpkins
calling out the name lingon not long
after a massive Dragon emerges from the
water and feeds on the pumpkins everyone
knows that dragons love Pumpkins this
huge Beast is revealed to be shaan's pet
and he frequently visits the lake to
feed it shaan shares everything with the
dragon including his wish to confess his
feelings to Tian afterwards Tien
secretly hands her father's Kung Fu
manual to shaan urging him to prepare
for the upcoming tournament from that
moment onward he embarks on his training
Journey one day he is in the middle of
meditation when a stone from his locket
begins to Glow here it's revealed that
this Stone was given to him by his late
father who also had explained to him
about its ability to exert control over
others although his father had advised
him to throw it into a deep Abyss shaan
had kept it as a locket now that he
realizes that it's distracting him from
his training he decides to throw it away
approaching a cliff shaan is on the
verge of discarding the stone when a
monkey intervenes seemingly Desiring the
object give me that when shaan refuses
to comply the monkey chases him and
pushes him into the water mysteriously
he is drawn deeper underwater but the
glowing Stone helps him resurface once
he swims out of the water the monkey
again tries to snatch the stone and also
bites his arm in the process take that
strangely the blood from the wound is
absorbed by the stone triggering a
significant reaction a mystical stick
emerges from the water and the stone
fuses with it forming a powerful
artifact referred to as the blood
sucking bead all the Masters witnessed
this Fusion sensing an impending danger
a short while later the mystical stick
comes to shaan but he is soon attacked
by a black clad woman named B yaow she
attempts to steal it from him but Shuki
and Tian intervene in the neck of time
the two of them team up and managed to
fend off the enemy later shaan is
shocked to learn that his wound has
miraculously disappeared revealing the
healing power of the stick later at
midnight B Yao infiltrates Dau peak one
more time to steal the stick despite
managing to obtain it the stick
unexpectedly pulls her back towards
shaan with this failed attempt the girl
flees in the following scene the master
approaches his disciples who are
practicing for the tournament while he
analyzes their skills U from long show
Peak shows up at the scene he
misunderstands Master Shang and remarks
that he isn't training shaan in a good
way this infuriates Tian who then
launches an attack on Jing Yu however
their fight is soon stopped by the
arrival of kiha the senior member of
long show school by whom Tian gets
captivated he apologizes to the master
on behalf of Jing Yu and takes him away
later on shaan is working in the farm
when he spots Tian embracing kiha this
breaks his heart so he runs towards a
field to spill his emotions out as he
arrives there he Witnesses bow running
towards him as she is being chased by a
group of soldiers despite being unaware
of the situation shaan joins her in a
frantic escape and leads her to a cave
while hiding there he inquires about the
reason for the solders pursuit to which
beow responds that she broke the school
rules following this shaan opens up
about his one-sided love while B
continues with her UNS successful
attempts to snatch the magical stick
after numerous tries beow decides to
stay there for the night and they hunt a
rabbit for dinner as their conversation
unfolds they share past stories to one
another beow recounts a harrowing
experience where she and her mother once
fell into a deep and dark cave after
days without any food her mother
sacrificed herself to feed beow did she
eat her mom she also goes on to express
her wish to go far away from everyone
where she can live her life in peace
hearing in this shaan tells her about a
place where he will be going for his
Advanced Kung Fu training and Promises
to take her along their hearttouching
conversation eventually leads them to
change their perception for one another
resulting in them becoming good friends
to seen them fast forwards to the day of
the tournament where students from all
schools assemble at a Shaolin Temple the
first round opponents are to be
determined through a random drawing of
balls and a student receiving a ball
marked with the number one will directly
advance to the second round as the
drawing initiates shui acquires the
lucky ball but she opts to exchange it
with shaoan believing that it's a
cowardly move to progress without a
fight after this the first round begins
and half of the students are eliminated
from the competition later shaan
competes in the second round and his
stick moves on its own an unsettle
metaphor if I've ever seen one defeating
his adversary in no time meanwhile we
learned that shui doesn't seem to be
well so her master sh U advises her to
walk from the tournament however Shuki
remains undeterred and vows to win the
whole competition hearing this her
master hands her a special medication
which can heal her temporarily it's
called a zenzu bean give it a taste in
the third round shaan confronts his
close friend Jing Yu while Tian faces
off against shui Jing Yu is clearly a
professional fighter in comparison to
shaan so he decides to fight slowly as
the fight Begins the sticks autonomous
move start troubling Jingo this leads
him to believe that shaan had been
hiding his true abilities making him
upset he then decides to use all of his
strength and fight with no mercy however
despite his formidable skills shaan's
stick proves to be dominant and it
eventually defeats Jing Yu the audience
who are unaware about this stick's
ability are shocked to witness this and
wonder how shaan got so powerful you
remember yesterday he was a little
although he wins shaan is weighed down
by the loss of of a cherished friend
because of the stick as a result he
walks up to a cliff and throws the stick
away on the other hand a fierce battle
ensues between Shuki and Tian with both
showcasing their exceptional fighting
skills however Shuki is ultimately able
to defeat Tian after this Shuki is
scheduled to fight with shaan in the
final round of the tournament the same
night shaan is approached by his pet
monkey that takes him to the shore of
the
stream there he discovers shui lying
weak on the ground he hurriedly helps
her up and provides her with medicine he
tries to inquire about her well-being
but the latter asks him to turn back and
not look at her after having her
medicine Shuki flies away from the scene
without any explanation the following
day everyone heads to the tournament's
location for The climactic Showdown
before the round begins Master Shang
approaches shaen with the sentiment that
Victory or defeat is inconsequential but
he doesn't want him to get hurt soon
after the The Duel begins and shaan
without his stick appears notably feeble
but despite enduring a barrage of blows
and injuries he isn't ready to give up
so easily at one point Shuki takes out
her sword to defeat him but shaan's
stick reappears thwarting her assault
the moment he grasps the rod his wounds
heal rapidly arousing suspicion among
the observing Masters after a while of
intense Clash both adversaries prepare
for their final blow as they Leed
towards each other shaan notices shuki's
deteriorating Health prompting him to
retreat seeing this Shuki also abandons
her attack and defeats him with a simple
push elsewhere beow is approached by her
leader who chastises her for failing to
retrieve the blood sucking bead here
it's revealed that bow is actually from
the demon sect and that she is here on a
mission to steal the stick from xiaan I
thought that was obvious but I guess
it's a Twist now that her Masters are
angry the sect has deployed several
demon Warriors to complete the mission
meanwhile the Kenyan sect's Masters who
recognized the stick as the demon sect's
weapon assess the unconscious shaan to
determine whether he belongs to the
demon sect just then Tian and other
disciples show up with the news of a
demon attack resulting in the demise of
numerous students sensing the gravity of
the situation the Master's restrain
shaan and have their disciples keep an
eye on him before heading to confront
The Intruders not long after weow sneaks
into the temple and uses her power to
render all the guards unconscious she
then frees shaan and takes him to the
demon king who happens to be her father
The Demon King seizes the blood sucking
bead but its fusion with shaan's blood
enables him to reclaim it infuriated The
Demon King opts to finish him off
disregarding his daughter's please he
knocks down his daughter and launches an
assault on shaan shortly after all the
Masters as well as their disciples IES
arrive at the scene to fight the demon
sect in the next scene the king Yun sect
Masters and shaan face the formidable
Demon King while the disciples engage in
combat with the other demon Warriors it
becomes evident that the demon sect is
much more powerful than the Kenyan sect
as the combined efforts of all Masters
prove insufficient against the might of
the demon king at a critical Moment The
Demon King unleashes his fiery prowess
prompting the Masters to unite in
defense with their thunderous abilities
witnessing the overwhelming strength of
the demon king shaan intervenes with his
freaking stick providing support to his
Masters he ultimately manages to defeat
the demons but he himself gets possessed
by a demonic soul in the process in the
aftermath the Masters recognize shaan's
evil dominance and as a result they
decide to kill him before he destroys
the world however shaan is so strong
that he overpowers all of his Masters
one after another when on the brink of
striking down Master Shang Tien steps in
prompting him to fatally strike her head
with his stick despite being in her
final moments she reaches out to him and
tries to snap him back to Consciousness
fortunately her efforts are successful
and shaan regains his composure he just
murdered the love of his life and
everybody lives happily ever after the
end no oh wait Shuki who is the last
surviving disciple Returns the favor by
deciding to let Shen go instead of
killing him the movie ends as shaen
carries be ya and sets off to somewhere
peaceful where he had promised to take
her subscribe for more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching